what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so previously we talked about the idea
of the century getting a movie you know
and how that how that film would play
out how people would respond to it you
know we touched a little bit on the
origin of the century different things
like that in this video I wanted to talk
about Moon Knight of course I said I
talked about moon on the last one so you
know we're gonna talk about it in this
one
but the more I thought about it the more
I kind of you know realized I wouldn't
necessarily give Moon Knight a movie I'd
give moon night a Netflix series and a
lot of you guys really seem to feel the
same way I was looking at the comments
you know with regards to moon on you
guys are like give them a Netflix series
and that seems to be the really popular
trend actually I was doing some google
searching and a lot of people were
saying they really wanted to see a moon
night show which i think is actually a
genius idea the cool thing about
Marvel's Netflix line is that it is part
and parcel to the whole Disney you know
Marvel brand but it's also separate in
the sense that it allows Marvel to take
a far darker tone with their characters
and they do with anything else you
probably wouldn't see the Punisher
running around and like shooting people
in the head in a movie with the Disney
banner in front of it ah you're probably
not gonna see that I mean certainly if
the Netflix series for a Punisher
translated into a film it would be right
at all I mean I don't how many of you
guys have seen that or finished it or
what-have-you about the time you get to
the end of the show it is gruesome
and it is violent and it's amazing I
love her for that reason but despite the
fact that it's got really every telltale
of Punisher match thrown in but for the
most part it has to remain isolated the
same thing with daredevil but the fact
that it's separate is what makes it cool
and makes it unique and so moondyne I
think would be this just incredible
addition to the Netflix line of stories
and here's a reason why on the whole the
Marvel Cinematic Universe focuses on
characters that are more tangible and
more realistic which is to say they sort
of adopt the Valiant Comics mantra the
world outside your window watching the
Marvel Netflix series you almost imagine
you could be walking down the streets of
New York right now in the real world you
could walk through Hell's Kitchen and
you could come across Jessica Jones you
can come across Luke Cage you can come
across daredevil or The Punisher or
somebody like that because where there
are a little more fantasy like when it
comes to the comics in the Netflix
series they're a lot more grounded and a
lot more realistic and so because of
that it's it's kind of cool I mean you
know Luke Cage for example in the comics
is strong
Incredible Hulk strong but he's a lot
stronger than you saw in the Netflix
series and the Netflix series his
strength was toned down for the most
part but his impenetrable skin is
bulletproof skin is one of the things
that made it kind of cool because that's
a part that is basically kept and it's
really a hallmark of his character with
moon night it's much the same way
originally moon night was created by a
guy named Doug mink and Ron purlins for
a line of Commerce called werewolf by
night which is really more of like the
the Marvel of horror brand and it's kind
of interesting back in the 1950s when
science fiction comics were all the rage
Atlas comics who came after timely
comics from the 1940s but was the
predecessor to Marvel in the 1960s sort
of the in-between
publication they were publishing a lot
of like science fiction and horror
comics before spider-man Thor Iron Man
all those guys really took off in
popularity and so because of that where
we'll find Knight maintained a lot of
those science fiction slash horror
themes and there were other characters
who did as well you know Morbius the
living vampire different things like
that but mu naught was created it really
just kind of tie into the werewolf by
night thing but what I think mood night
brings to the table isn't necessarily
the depiction of Batman in the in the
Marvel Line it's really the multiple
personalities that he has one of the big
arguments not made this argument before
on both sides
to be honest I've kind of walked a fence
even though I probably shouldn't moon
night fans hate me for doing it really
moon night in a lot of ways is kind of
like Batman but he's not like that I
mean he's like Batman insofar as he uses
you know razor sharp pieces of equipment
different things like that kind of like
batarangs or shaped like little you know
different things like that but like
those are the people and so on and so
forth but he's not nearly on the same
level as a detective he's wealthy but
that's a whole nother personality and
that's where things get kind of cool for
the character of Moon Knight he is a guy
named Mark Specter or at least is one of
the personalities he has and more
expector was originally a mercenary that
basically survived an attempted killing
and he was granted a second chance to
become an avatar on earth for an
Egyptian god named khonshu and the
result is that he sort of came back and
he you know fights crime as an avatar of
khonshu carries out his weird campaigns
every once in a while whenever khonshu
gets involved but he's basically got
four distinct personalities there is
moon knight which is the crime fighter
there's mark specter the mercenary there
is Jake Lockley the cab driver and then
there's Steve grant the millionaire is a
billionaire I think it's the millionaire
but you know you basically have all
these different personalities that are
intertwined and the result is that more
often than not overall the character
sometimes doesn't know which one of
those is real he doesn't know which one
he actually is is he really Steve Grant
and all the other personalities are fake
is he really Jake Lockley and the other
personalities are fake and that's the
question that readers are posed all the
time in this context which one of these
people is he really and that's kind of
the cool thing because it really has
these tones of like Legion for example
you know Legion on FX was an amazing
show I mean really the Shadow King
aspect was kind of cool but it was
interesting because you didn't really
know what was going on that it was
really more of a puzzle and that's one
of the things that people like they
loved watching shows well they kind of
have to simultaneously figure out what's
going on while also enjoying the
evolution of the puzzle and that's one
of the cool things that Moon Knight
could bring to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in the form of the Netflix line
you pick up with these different
personalities you pick up with these
different things that are going on and
at first it might seem as though he's
just doing detective work and he's just
using these for the purpose of you know
hey I'm I'm Jake Lockley because I had
to keep my ear to the ground and know
when troubles are brewing I'm going to
be Steve grant because I have to fight
corporate crime mark speck for the
mercenary because I have to keep my
skills maintained and I'm gonna have all
that consolidated under the banner of
Moon Knight who's gonna fight crime but
as this show progresses he began to
realize he gets lost in his own
personalities that he begins to question
which one he really is and then as you
watch the show you start to question it
as well but which one of these
personalities was true when this person
was born into the world what name did
their parents give him did they give him
the name of March Spectre Jake Lockley
or Steve grant which one of these is
actually him and while they are all the
same person it does create this really
interesting intricate web of just
confusion and interest and puzzle
solving and all that kind of stuff and
it all makes sense in the end
well the dust was settled and everything
will make sense when the show is over I
wouldn't imagine it'd be a very good
idea to leave people on cliffhangers
because you would kill interest in the
character at that point but it does
create some pretty interesting things
because with Moon Knight not really
having any traditional powers to speak
of which is to say he can't fly or
anything like that with him basically
being a street-level character he fits
right in alongside Jessica Jones that
Luke Cage and iron fists and all those
different guys he fits in perfectly with
all those characters
that's so again I think it'd be kind of
cool I think it'd be really really
really interesting to say nothing of the
fact that his costume looks amazing
that's one of my favorite things to see
I've got a comic book conventions and
you'll have those guys I'll have a white
mask and they'll have the moon shaped
crescent on the on the mask and they'll
have like a white suit and they'll have
the white shoes and the white gloves and
it just you know completely dressed in
white and it looks amazing
I've seen some where it was homemade and
it looked cool and then I've seen some
where was professionally made and it
looked incredible so there's all
different types of cosplay with that
kind of stuff we're just one of my
favorite things to see whenever it is
that I go to concert I'll of seeing you
know the lengths people will go to to
adapt their favorite characters and to
you know costumes they can wear but the
fact remains you know I think that moon
dye can really bring a breath of fresh
air because I think for a lot of people
they look at the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and they say okay then we've
had the same characters on Netflix for
quite some time initially you started
out with daredevil then it went into
Jessica Jones and Luke Cage and you know
iron fist and each character teased the
others appearances we didn't know if
they were actually gonna show up you
know we had daredevil season two that
teased you know the idea of Punisher
getting his own series or at least
normal kind of toying with it and then
realizing how popular the Punisher was
launching his own series but for the
most part it's just the same characters
you know it's almost like nobody else
allowed Club you know it's kind of like
this inner circle and I think that
people look at the Netflix arm in the
same way they look at the movie arm in
the sense that they basically look
around they say we need something new we
need something fresh we're getting kind
of tired of seeing the same old
characters doing the same old thing
we want something just new dynamic and
fresh that's why guardians of the galaxy
succeeded so well guardians of the
galaxy was a great film when James Gunn
is an incredible filmmaker but it was
also so different from everything we saw
it took place out in space we saw
different parts of the Marvel Universe
we'd never seen before in movie form we
learned there's a much bigger universe
out there outside of just whatever it is
that's going on on earth we saw all
these different cool concepts all sort
of brought together alien races the
Infinity stones were fleshed out even
more than they had been before and all
kinds of stuff was going on and so in my
mind you know even if it's not
necessarily on his grand of a scale as
guardians of the galaxy mood 9 could
definitely freshen things up a bit you
know provide a little bit of vibrancy
well not really vibrancy because he's
not like a happy character he's kind of
a miserable guy and his stories are
pretty dark but do you guys understand
what I'm saying
definitely freshen things up a bit and
inject some new blood into the into the
the Marvel Universe which I think at
this point is really kind of needed you
know I think we really need something
fresh something new that's why I'm so
looking forward to Black Panther it
would kill monger Michael B Jordan is
one of the best actors that I've ever
seen he's incredible and I have no doubt
he's gonna be absolutely amazing in that
role Carol Danvers as Captain Marvel
whatever you know awaits us after the
events of infinity war and Infinity
Gauntlet but again you know let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section I'm kind of curious to see what
you guys come up with
you guys really seem passionate about
the idea of seeing like Moon Knight in
shows or you know on Netflix or in movie
form or something along those lines but
yeah let me know what you guys think
about this about this whole thing you
know about Moon Knight with that being
said guys we're gonna go ahead and bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come as explained to make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the robb core you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]